in this video we're going to talk about
pre-algebra we're gonna go through a
typical pre-algebra
review going through all the different
types of questions that you might
encounter when you're doing a
pre-algebra course we're gonna go step
by step you might want to try and pause
the video and do some of these questions
on your own and then compare with what I
go over with you here in this video
we're gonna be going through 82
different questions if you have any
questions about any particular problems
that I'm doing in this video I have
additional problems like this on my
Mario's math tutor YouTube channel so
you can get some more practice there but
let's jump into this video the first
question how would you simplify this
expression 14 plus 4 divided by 2 all
divided by 9 minus 2 times 3 plus 1 so
what they're testing us on here is the
order of operation so remember the
PEMDAS the parentheses exponents
multiplication division addition
subtraction so there's four levels of
importance about what you want to do
first second third fourth there's not
any parentheses so we can't do any of
that
there aren't any exponents so we're
gonna go to multiplication and division
4 divided by 2 is 2 so we have 14 plus 2
2 times 3 is 6 so we have 9 minus 6 plus
1 so now we've gone all the way down to
addition and subtraction we're going to
do the numerator 14 plus 2 which is 16
and then the denominator 9 minus 6 which
is 3 plus 1 which is 4 and 16 divided by
4 is 4 so that's how you want to do it
you want to treat the numerator in the
denominator kind of separately and then
follow the order of operations so
definitely something important to review
number 2 translate into an algebraic
expression 3 less then the quotient of
some number and 5 ok so how do we do
this one well the quotient means divide
some number in 5 we don't know what the
number is so we're gonna say n divided
by 5 but we want 3 less than that so
minus 3 so that's your final result now
some students mistake me we'll see 3
less than and they'll write 3 minus
because they're thinking about doing
like a direct translation like whatever
comes first you write on the left
whatever comes second you write on the
right etc but in this case when you take
3 less than your
she's subtracting it three from this
quantity so you want to be careful with
your order there okay for number three
it says name the properties shown so two
parts a and B but for a we have two plus
three plus X the quantity equals the
quantity two plus three plus X now
notice that the two three and X are in
the same order on the left side of the
equation as they are on the right the
only difference is that here you have
the three plus X grouped and here you
have the two plus three group so what
would you call that property well this
is called the associative property of
addition so I'm just going to abbreviate
so city property of addition and the
idea is associate is like you're
grouping okay just like your friends you
know you have a you associate with
certain people here you're doing this
group first here you're doing this group
first the two sides of the equations
that are going to be equivalent that's
called the associative property now for
letter B we have five times 3y equals 3y
10 is five now notice how the order has
actually been changed what do you call
that property this one's actually called
the commutative property so when you
change the order that's called commuting
like a commutative property of
multiplication so I'm just abbreviating
there okay let's go over to number four
now this one says graph the points on
the coordinate plane so we have ABC and
D how would you plot these on the
coordinate plane well remember when you
work with these coordinates it's like an
alphabetical order it's like XYZ so the
X controls left and right Y controls up
and down usually I do the X first so
negative two means I'm going to go left
two from the origin so left two from the
center point here and then I'm going to
go up three because that's positive
three so just remember left is negative
right is positive down is negative up is
positive and so that's going to be point
a right about there for letter B we've
got a four negative one so again the X
is four so you're going to start at the
origin right four and then Y is negative
one we're gonna go down one that's B now
keep in mind that this is the first
quadrant second quadrant third quadrant
and fourth quadrant you go in a
counterclockwise fashion
for point C zero negative two sometimes
this trick students when the x
coordinate zero zero means you're not
going left to right you're just going
down two so that's going to be point C
and then for point D negative one
negative four you're going left one and
then you're going down four because the
Y is negative that's point D number five
is very similar to number four the only
difference here is it says write the
ordered pair for each point so here
they're giving us the points we have to
write the coordinates how would you do
this one well let's see for point W
we're at zero left or right so that
means the x coordinates zero and then
we're going up one two three that's our
y coordinate for point X we're actually
going right three that's positive three
that we're going down one number down is
negative okay for letter y point y how
would you find the coordinates for that
one you're going left two so that's a
negative two and then you're going up
one that's a positive one and you've got
it okay for number six it says does the
scatterplot show a positive negative or
no correlation so what do you think for
this one when you look at these data
points here is it showing a positive
negative or no correlation well notice
it's trending down to the right very
clearly like that if you were to draw a
line of best fit it would be somewhere
in that region there and then because it
has a negative slope or it's decreasing
as you go to the right this is actually
called a negative correlation if it was
trending up to the right that's positive
like a positive slope and if they were
kind of scattered there's not really a
trend at all then we'd say relatively no
correlation okay number seven we have
the absolute value of negative four
minus the absolute value of negative two
how would you do that one well now
remember a lot of times students get
confused with the absolute value the
absolute value what you do is you treat
it like parentheses you do whatever is
on the inside first and then the end
result is going to be positive so
absolute value of negative four is just
for the absolute value of negative 2 is
just 2 and we have 4 minus 2 which just
equals to some students mistakenly think
the absolute value means make it the
opposite that's not right absolute
values going to end up making the end
result positive okay so for number E we
have is it less than greater than or
equal to and you cannot remember this
because the less than kind of looks like
an L tilted so this is less than
it points to the smaller quantity and it
opens to the larger quantity okay so in
this case negative 4 is it less than
greater than or equal to negative 3 now
sometimes it's helpful to draw a number
line so here's negative 4 here's
negative 3 negative 2 negative 1 0 right
so what happens it looks like 4 is
bigger than 3 right but negative 4 means
it's a larger negative number which
means it's further to the left okay so
it's actually smaller so negative 4 is
less than negative 3 okay and that's how
you do that one number 9 we're
evaluating and here what it's talking
about is having us practice our positive
and negative numbers adding subtracting
multiplying and dividing sometimes this
is a little bit of a sticking point for
some students so you might want to
review this concept but for letter A
what do you think for this one negative
15 plus 7 well this one's going to be
negative 8 and the reason is is like
imagine if you're walking backwards 15
steps and then you walk forward 7 steps
you're further back by 8 steps from
where you started write for letter B we
have negative 6 minus negative 8 now
what you can do when you're subtracting
is you can think of it as adding the
opposite so if you change the
subtraction problem into addition
problem you have to change that second
quantity to the opposite sign so if it's
positive you make it negative it's
negative you make it positive but
negative 6 plus 8 again we have you walk
backwards 6 steps then you walk forwards
8 steps you're actually 2 steps further
ahead than from where you started for
the letter C you're multiplying now so
negative 4 times 3 would be how much
negative 12 remember when you have a
negative times a positive you get a
negative if you multiply two negatives
together you get a positive okay so just
remember if the signs are opposite
you're gonna get a negative if they're
the same you're gonna get a positive
okay and for letter D negative 64
divided by negative 8 the rules for
multiplication and division are the same
if you have two negatives you're going
to end up with a positive so 64 divided
by 8 is 8 and negative a negative is a
positive and you got it so go ahead and
review the positive and negative numbers
if you need to do that I've got some
videos on my channel to help you with
that number 10 we've got right as a
decimal so we've got a fraction
or thirds how do you convert that to a
decimal what do you think well when you
look at this fraction bar see that 4/3
that fresh mark just means divided by so
it's 4 that's being divided by 3 3 goes
into 4 once
1 times 3 is 3 okay and we can put a
placeholder 0 okay and we can bring this
down 4 minus 3 is 1 3 goes into 10 how
many times 3 we bring up our decimal
point right on our division bar there 3
times 3 is 9 1 bring down another 0 3
goes into 10 three and you can see it's
one point 3 3 3 3 repeating so we could
write this as 1.3 and put the bar over
the 3 to show that it repeats okay for
number 11 it says write as a fraction or
a mixed number so 2 point 3 6 how would
we write this as a fraction or a mixed
number well one way to do this is if you
pronounce this in the correct you know
fashion it'll tell you how to write it
it's 2 and 36 hundredths so you see how
I did that
2 and 3600 so whatever that last place
is for the decimal this is the
hundredths place we have 36 hundredths
that's 36 over a hundred now we can
reduce this a little bit 2 goes into 36
18 times 2 goes into 150 times okay and
then we can reduce it again 2 goes into
both of these so that would be 9 and 25
so this is 2 and 9 twenty fifths you can
check your answer if you do 9 divided by
25 you're going to get 0.36 so you can
see 2.36
for letter B though we've got a
repeating decimal how do we write this
repeating decimal back into a fraction
or a mixed number well there's a little
technique that you learn like in when
you're studying pre-algebra there's
other ways to do this but let me just
show you see that you make your number
equal to two point seven repeating so
seven seven seven dot dot if we multiply
both sides of the equation by 10 this
would be 10 times N equals and if we
multiply this by 10 you're just moving
that decimal one place to the right that
becomes twenty seven point seven seven
seven seven dot dot what you can do then
is if you subtract ten n minus one and
is 9
here you can see the seventh repeating
portion is canceling 27 minus 2 is 25
and if we divide both sides by 9 you can
see that our number is actually 25
ninths and that's going to be your
fractional you can also write this 9
goes into 25 how many times 2 with 7
left over so it's two and seven nights
and again you can divide these and show
it to yourself that you're getting two
point seven seven seven seven etc okay
number 12 it says identify 2 which set
the number belongs so we've got a B and
C negative 3 square root of 2 and 4/5
and just a quick refresher there's
different types of numbers we have the
real numbers okay which is most of the
numbers that you're familiar with these
are not including the imaginary numbers
imaginary numbers we're going to take
the square root of a negative number
because usually get into that when you
get into algebra 2 so all the numbers
are going to be in the set of real
numbers and then it's gonna there's a
split it can either be rational or
irrational so you can see rational these
groups irrational is the ones in these
groups but remember rational means like
a ratio anything that can be written as
a fraction of an integer divided by an
integer now you might be saying to
yourself Oh Mario what's an integer well
an integer is any round number like
negative 3 negative 2 negative 1 0 1 2 3
etc so it can be negative 0 or positive
but it couldn't be 3.5 okay that would
not be an integer and then we have the
whole numbers and the whole numbers are
just from zero and then the positive
integers 1 2 3 4 etc so let's see if we
can do these so negative 3 what set of
numbers would that be in well you can
see it's going to be a real number so
I'll just write real and it's also going
to be a rational number because it can
be written as a ratio of negative 3 over
1 so that's rational okay a ratio and
it's an integer because you can see it's
negative 3 but is it a whole number no
because it's not one of zero or one of
the positive integers okay let's go to
square root of 2 so square root of 2 is
it real yes okay is it rational or
irrational now can it be written as the
ratio of an integer divided by an
integer well square root of 2 if you do
this on your calculator it's gonna be
like 1.4 dot dot it doesn't repeat it
doesn't terminate meaning it doesn't
stop so
this one it actually cannot be written
as a ratio so this is actually
irrational and then that's as far as we
can go though so you might choose sets
that square root of two is in and then
four letters see we have four-fifths you
can see that this is again real and it's
rational you can see it's a ratio of an
integer over an integer so we'll say
rational and is it an integer no you can
see it's not a round number negative
zero or positive so that's it that's the
only two sets that that one's in okay so
for number thirteen now we're getting
into working with fractions so adding
subtracting multiplying dividing etc
with fractions and mixed numbers so
let's review this so negative two and
two-thirds times four and a half how
would you multiply those together well
what a lot of students like to do here
is just convert these into improper
fractions you take the denominator times
the whole number plus the numerator so
this is going to be negative well ignore
the negative for a moment here so three
times two is six plus two is eight
so this is eight thirds but the whole
thing is negative okay two times four is
eight plus one is nine so this is 9 over
two and we're multiplying these together
now what you can do is you can multiply
the numerators together the dynamics
together and then divide or you can
reduce top and bottom or on the
diagonals top and bottom so that's why
I'm going to do two goes in here once
two goes in here four three goes into
here once 3 goes in here three times now
when I multiply across I have negative 4
times 3 is negative 12 one times one is
one
anything divided by 1 is itself so we
just get negative 12 so that's how you
would work with multiplying mixed
numbers now for number fourteen we're
dividing dividing is very similar to
multiplying right so when you divide you
use the keep it change it flip it
technique so you keep the first fraction
you multiply by the reciprocal of the
second fraction but first we have to
convert them into mixed the mixed
numbers into improper fractions so 5
times 2 is 10 plus 3 is 13 so this is 13
fifths whole thing's negative ok divided
by five times one is five plus two is
seven seven fists the whole thing is
negative but remember how we said that
division is like multiplying either
reciprocal so I'm just going to flip
that over
again you can reduce numerator and
denominator okay we're on the diagonals
numerator denominator so when I multiply
across here I'm just getting negative 13
sevenths
I'm sorry negative times a negative
would actually be positive and 7 goes
into 13 one whole time with 6 left over
so this is actually simplifying down to
one and six seventh okay so now 15 we're
getting into adding fractions so when
you add fractions
unlike multiplying and dividing you have
to have a common denominator so what's
the smallest number that 5 goes into and
10 also goes into well they both go into
10 so it looks like 10 is gonna be our
smallest denominator I'm going to
multiply the top and bottom by 2 for
this fraction like is a 6/10 so 6/10 is
the same as a 3/5 so 6 tenths plus 7
tenths is 13 tenths 10 goes into 13 once
with 3 left over so it's 1 in 3/10 for
number 16 were subtracting mixed numbers
so let's first convert them into
improper fractions so 4 times 3 is 12
plus 1 is 13 so we have 13 4 minus 3
times 1 is 3 plus 2 gives us 5/3 now we
want to get a common denominator it
looks like 12 is a smallest number that
4 & 3 both go into so to make this 12
I'm gonna multiply the bottom by 3 but I
have to do the same thing to the top to
make this one twelve after multiply the
bottom by 4 I have to do the same thing
to the top because 3 divided by 3 is 1 4
divided by 4 is 1 when you multiply by 1
it doesn't change the value of the
fraction so we get 39 12 - 20 12 which
is equal to 19 12 12 goes into 19 once
with 7 left over right so that's 1 + 7
12 okay number 17 is very similar to
number 16 here we're just adding two
mixed numbers same process see if you
can do this one on your own again you
want to convert into improper fractions
so 3 times 5 is 15 plus 1 is 16 over 3 5
times 2 is 10 plus 3 is 13 over 5 common
an honor it's going to be 15 so I'm
gonna multiply the bottom here by 5 in
the top by 5 top by 3 bottom by 3 so 15
times 6 is 85th
teens +39 15 which gives us 119 15 okay
so now you want to go back and convert
this into a mixed number here so 15 goes
in here about let's see I think seven
times so that's seven times 15 is a
hundred and five with 14 left over so
that's seven and 14 15 okay and number
18 what we have here is they're testing
us on the distributive property so
remember the distributive property see
how the negative four is right next to
that parentheses are side by side with
nothing in between that means that
they're multiplied together and so with
the distributive property you take
what's ever on the outside you
distribute it into the parentheses and
what you're doing is you're taking
what's on the outside and you're
multiplying it by what's on the inside
so negative 4 times 2x is negative 8x
negative 4 times negative 5 is a
positive 20 when you see a minus sign
you just think of it as a negative
number group that together so negative 5
times negative 4 positive 20 which is
like plus 20 and you got it that's the
distributive property okay number 19 it
says simplify so we want to take this
expression you want to try to condense
it down so how would you do this one 2x
minus 5 plus 4 X plus 8 so what you want
to do is combine like terms and what
some people like to do is kind of like
circle the like terms so for example
you've got 2x + 4 X and here you've got
let's say negative 5 and positive 8 so I
put different shapes around like terms
that correspond with one another so you
can think of these on like little sheets
of paper you can move them around and
you know group the ones together that
are similar so we've got 2x + 4 X which
is 6x we have negative 5 plus positive 8
which is positive 3 and you've got it
now all these are added together if you
see a - just think of it as a negative
if you see a plus just think as a
positive but they're all added together
let's go to number 20 now so it says
simplify this expression so 3 times a
minus 2 - 4 a plus 6 so how would you do
that one well here you can see we've got
the distributive property so we have to
multiply that 3 into the parentheses and
then we'll bring down the negative 480
and the 6 now we want to combine like
terms we've got 3a and negative 4a so
that adds up to negative
and we have negative 6 and positive 6
that's actually 0 that cancels out so it
just comes out to negative 8 let's go to
number 21 now we're getting into solving
some equations and we've got basically
like one step then to step then
multi-step equations so let's start off
with some of the basic ones number 22
it's sorry 21 it's to solve X minus 4
equals 9 so we want to get the variable
by itself on one side of the equal sign
on one side of the equation we want to
find out what X is but to do that you
have to do the inverse or the opposite
operation so what I mean by that is
instead of subtracting 4 to get rid of
this minus 4 we have to do the opposite
of subtracting which is to add 4 if you
do it to the left you want to do it to
the right to keep the equation balanced
you can kind of think of this as a line
or a divider these cancel we get x
equals 9 plus 4 which is 13 now the nice
thing about algebra is that you can
check your answer if you take the 13 you
put it back in for X 13 minus 4
yes that's 9 so you know you got it
right so let's go to number 22 so M plus
7 equals negative 2 we want to get M by
itself some things we have to get rid of
the seven what's the opposite of adding
7 that's subtracting 7 whatever you do
to left you want to do it to the right
keep the equation balanced this comes
out to 0 those cancel out
negative 2 minus 7 is negative 9 again
if you want to check your answer put
negative 9 back into the original
problem and check ok for number 23 we've
got a division-one here we've got e
divided by negative 4 equals 7 what's
the opposite of dividing by negative 4
multiplying both sides by negative 4 so
these cancel and we get 7 times negative
4 is negative 28 okay now for number 24
now we have 9 times f notice they're
right next to each other that means
they're multiplied together what's the
opposite of multiplying by 9 dividing
both sides by 9 to keep it balanced so
these cancel out this just gives you a F
equals negative 3 and you got it okay
now we've got a little bit more of a
two-step equation ok so we've got X
divided by 3 minus 5 equals 4 now what I
like to think about is we're trying to
work from the outside in towards that
variable we're trying to get that X by
itself so working from the outside in
I'd probably get rid of this 5 here
first so instead of subtracting 5 I
would add 5 to both sides
these cancel so now we're just down to X
divided by 3 equals 9 what's the
opposite of dividing by 3 well
multiplying both sides by 3 9 times 3 is
27 and you got it now if you want to
check your work again you put it back in
27 divided by 3 is 9 9 minus 5 is 4 the
true sides may actually know you got it
right
4:26 same thing we've got a two-step
equation again think about working from
the outside in towards that variable Y
how would you do this one 2y plus 6
equals 4 if I was going to do it I would
subtract 6 first so that's gonna give
you negative 2 and then I'd say what's
the opposite of multiplying by 2
dividing both sides by 2
so we get y equals negative 1 and you
got it okay number 27 it says translate
into an equation for less than the
product of negative 2 in a number is 5
okay so how would you do that one well
let's take a look so when you see the
word product that means multiply okay
negative 2 and a number so we don't know
what the number is we're gonna make that
a variable so negative 2 times n okay
and for less than that so for less than
the product so that'd be minus 4 is
whenever you see the word is that's
equals 5 and that's your equation then
you can go on to solve it if you want
but they just asked us to translate into
an equation so let's go to number 28 now
we're finding perimeter and area
remember perimeter is the distance
around the object area is the inside of
the object right so when we find the
perimeter for this one we're going to
want to add up all the exterior size as
if you're walking around the outer edge
of the object so that'd be 4 plus 7
which is 11 plus 10 which is 21 and the
units are just going to be centimeters
because it's just like one dimensional
just lengths but if you want to find the
area since it's a triangle we have to
use the formula 1/2 base times height
now the base is the bottom this is kind
of like what it sits on here which is 10
times the height that's the
perpendicular distance okay a triangle
is kind of like a mountain so imagine
you climb the mountain it's the shortest
distance from the peak to the base ok so
that perpendicular distance so that's
going to be
times three which is 30 times 1/2 which
is 15 centimeters squared
okay so area is going to be
two-dimensional you're filling it up
with one by one centimeters square okay
for number 29 it says solve X minus 2
equals negative 3x plus 6 and this is a
little bit more challenging equation
because you have variables on both sides
of the equation but the key is to get
the variables on one side and the
numbers on the opposite side of the
equation so what I'm going to do here is
I'm going to get the variables on the
left which means I have to get rid of
them here on the right whenever you want
to get rid of something you want to do
the opposite so instead of subtracting
3x what I'm going to do is I'm going to
add 3x this way the negative 3x and
positive 3x cancel so we're just left
with 6 on the right and 3x plus 1 x is
4x minus 2 okay so now we want to get
the variables by themselves we want to
get the numbers on the other side so
instead of subtracting 2 we're going to
add 2 okay that way the these will
cancel out and so now we just have 4x is
equal to 8 instead of multiplying by 4
we're going to do the app so we're going
to divide both sides by 4 and so you can
see x equals 8 over 4 which is equal to
2 and you've got it now if you want to
check your answer you can always put it
back in make sure the left side and the
right side balance right okay so for
number 30 we're getting into solving
inequalities again remember this is like
owl for less than so 15 is less than
negative 3 minus 2 why how would you
solve that inequality well it's just
like solving equations you want to get
the variable by itself but when you
solve inequalities you really want the
variable to be on the left when you're
completely finished solving the
inequality but to start off with what
we're gonna do is we're gonna add 3 to
both sides because we want to get the
numbers and the variables on opposite
sides now here we're going to do is I'm
gonna get Y by itself by doing the
opposite of multiplying by negative 2
I'm gonna divide both sides by negative
2 well what's interesting is when you
multiply or divide both sides of the
inequality by a negative quantity this
inequality sign actually flips so
instead of less than it's going to
become greater than here and that's
negative 9 now the last step again like
I said is you want that variable on the
left so I'm going to take this whole
inequality I'm going to pick it up and
flip it over so that the variable is on
the left and number is on the right now
what we're gonna do is we're going to go
to the number line we're gonna graph
this so here's negative 9 right here
here's negative 10 right here here's
negative 8 right here now Y is less than
so I'm gonna make this an open circle
meaning it doesn't include negative 9
but it's all the values that are less
than meaning smaller than negative 9 so
we're gonna graph to the left okay so
this is a set of solutions not just one
answer but any point less center to the
left of negative 9 okay so for 31 this
is very similar see if you can do this
one we've got three X's greater than or
equal to negative 12 again we just want
to get X by itself so instead of
multiplying by 3 I'm gonna divide both
sides by 3 X is greater than or equal to
negative 4 now notice I didn't flip the
inequality sign because I'm dividing by
a positive number
only if you multiply or divide both
sides by a negative number does that
inequality sign change direction so here
you can see it's greater than or equal
to equal to means it includes this point
greater than means as you go to the
right so negative 4 negative 3 all the
values that are greater than or equal to
negative 4 okay 432 we've got a little
bit more challenging equation to solve
see if you can do this one but what I'm
going to do is I'm gonna start by
simplifying the left side and the right
side so I've got 7 X minus 7 just doing
that distributive property here I'm
going to combine like terms negative 2x
and positive 9 X is 7 X plus 5 and then
here what I'm going to do is I'm going
to subtract 7x from both sides notice
the variables are cancelling out on both
sides of the equation and we're only
left with negative 7 equals 5 which
really doesn't make any sense negative 7
cannot equal 5 these this is not true so
what this tells us is is that there's no
solution to this equation now if it came
out to negative 7 equals negative 7 or 5
equals 5 or the same thing equals the
same thing then it would be an infinite
number of solutions and then if we just
ended up with a X by itself and then
equal something then we just have one
solution so this is kind of a special
case when the variable cancels out you
have to see if it's always true or never
true okay and the number 33 it says
write as a unit rate okay so see that
word unit unit means like 1 so we want
to convert here 21 dollars for 3 games
how much does it cost just for one game
and so what we can do is we can set this
up as a ratio 21
/ / means like / three games but what we
want is we just want how much does it
cost for one game right because that's
one unit so you can see here how am I
getting from three to one I'm dividing
by three so if I divide the denominator
by three I have to divide the numerator
by three so that comes out to seven
dollars per one game so that's the unit
rate okay number 34 it says convert 20
feet per second into miles per hour so
this is what they call a unit conversion
problem how would you do this one well
what you can do is you can start off
with what they're giving us which is 20
feet per one second and what we need to
do is we need to make our way over two
miles per hour so let's start with the
feet we know that there's 5,280 feet in
one mile now what's interesting is when
you set up these conversion factors see
how the feet in the denominator cancel
with feet in the numerator so now we're
just left with miles so that's we're
converting the unit's but now we need to
go from seconds to hours so we know that
there are 60 seconds in one minute okay
notice the seconds and the numerator
cancels with the seconds in the
denominator so you know you set this up
the correct way if you set it up the
other way they're not kind of the unit's
they're not going to cancel that you
don't want and then again we want to get
rid of the minutes so we know that
there's 60 minutes in one hour again
notice the minutes in the numerator are
cancelling with the minutes in the
denominator you can see now all we're
left with is miles in the numerator
hours in the denominator so miles per
hours what we're left with so all we
have to do now is multiply all the
numerators together all the denominators
together and then divide so let me do
that in the calculator so we've got 20
times 60 times 60 which is coming out to
72,000 so let me just write that down
here so 72,000 and then 1 times 5,280
times 1 times 1 and now we have to do is
just take that 72,000 divided by 5,280
and we're getting about 13.6 i'm
rounding miles per hour so that's how
you convert units using these conversion
factors now for 35 it says do the race
form a proportion what exactly is a
proportion a proportion is a ratio
that's equal to another ratio or like a
fraction it's equal to another fraction
there's a couple different ways to do
this one way to do it is to see if you
can reduce the fractions to lowest terms
if the two fractions are equal then you
know that it forms of proportion
the other way to do it is you can like
cross multiply you can multiply on the
diagonals and see if that's the same as
a product of the other diagonals but in
this case I think I'm just going to
reduce so if I divide both the top and
bottom by 4 I get 3/5 if I divide the
top and bottom here by 5 that's going to
give us three fifths and you can see
that 3/5 equals 3/5 so yes this does
form a proportion okay let's go to
number 36 it says what is the scale
factor if 3 inches represents one foot
right one foot so see you have like a
blueprint and like on the blueprint it
says like three inches equals one foot
in real life but you want to know the
scale factor meaning like how many times
larger is it or how many times smaller
is it well the first thing we need to do
is convert these units so that they're
the same so we know that one foot is
actually like 12 inches and what we're
going to do is see because of the feet
that's like our new dimension and the
three inches was our original dimension
I'm going to take the new divided by the
old so twelve inches divided by three
inches is actually four so you can see
the scale factor is four it's like it's
four times larger in real life so just
remember new divided by old to get your
scale factor but make sure the
dimensions are the same for number 37 it
says solve the proportion now we've been
talking about proportions here a little
bit there's two different ways like I
said like one way that a lot of students
like to do it is just multiply on the
diagonals so 3 times 24 is 72 and that's
going to be equal to this diagonal
multiplied together which is 18x and now
all you have to do is divide both sides
by 18 and so you can see that X is
coming out to 4 the other way to do it
is you could say like Oh 18 divided by 6
is 3 so then 24 divided by 6 is 4 you
know that's another way to do it but a
lot of students just cross multiply so I
would recommend that method so for 38 it
says if 2 inches equals 12 feet in real
life so say again like that blue print
diagram that I was talking about earlier
what are the real-life dimensions of a
room
measures three inches by four inches
okay so there's a couple different ways
to do this one way to do it is to set up
a proportion you have the scale which is
two inches to real-life which is twelve
feet and then let's say on the blueprint
or the diagram three inches equals X
feet and we can do the same thing over
here we could say two inches represents
12 feet and four inches on the diagram
equals you know X feet in real life so
if we go ahead and solve this now let's
cross multiply we have 2x equals three
times 12 which is 36 divided by 2x
equals 18 feet here we have 2 times x
equals 4 times 12 which is 48 divided by
2 x equals 24 feet so it's really going
to be 18 feet by 24 feet in real life so
you just set a proportion scale to
actual scale to actual you want to keep
it consistent you don't want to flip
this ratio you want make sure you're
comparing inches 2 feet inches 2 feet
diagram to real life diagram to real
life like that okay so for 39 now it
says the triangles are similar find the
missing side now what's interesting to
point out here is that notice how these
markings on the triangle see these
angles that correspond they match up see
I've got two marks there two marks there
three marks there are three marks there
so when I match up these triangles I
know that the corresponding angles are
matching up and then the corresponding
sides the sides that match up are going
to be proportional so in this case we
can see 4 is 2 9 okay as 3 is 2 X now
notice I'm keeping this consistent left
to right left to right small to large
small to large okay so now if we cross
multiply you can see we've get 4 x
equals 3 times 9 which is 27 divide both
sides by 4 and you can see x equals
let's see 4 goes into 27 6 times that's
24 with 3 left over so B 6 and 3/4 okay
so now for number 40 it says write the
percentages sorry the percent as a
fraction right so how do we convert from
percentages into fractions well one
thing to realize is that when you talk
about percent cent means like a hundred
like 100 cents in a dollar hundred years
in a century 100 feet on a centipede
right so 32 percent
per number always said purrs / so 32 /
hundred right / a hundred so that not
all if they do is reduce it looks like
two goes into both of these so that'd be
16 50th two goes into both of these
that's eight twenty fifths and that's as
far as we can reduce it so eight 2015 as
thirty-two percent okay number forty-one
it says write the fraction as a
percentage so how do we go for a
fraction to a percent well one thing to
look at is when you look at a fraction
see that division bar right there that
fraction bar that means / so 7 divided
by 4 so 4 goes into 7 let's see well 4
goes into 7 once 1 times 4 is 4 7 minus
4 is 3 we can bring down that
placeholder 0 4 goes into 30 7 that's 28
subtract bring down another placeholder
4 goes into 25 with none left over so
this is 1.75 now we've converted it from
a fraction to a decimal but to convert
from a decimal to a percent now what you
do is you move that decimal point two
places to the right and that's a hundred
and seventy-five percent now there's
more than one way to do this problem
what you can also do is you can say well
percent means per hundred so if I can
get the denominator to be a hundred then
I've got my percentage so 4 times 25 is
a hundred if I multiply the denominator
by 25 to multiply the numerator by 25 7
times 25 is 175 percent so that's
another way to do it but I think most
students like to just convert it to a
decimal and then a percent for 42 it
just says write the percentage as a
decimal so now we're going the other way
so when you have a percent to go to a
decimal you move that decimal point two
places to the left now if there's
nothing there you want to put
placeholders so this is actually equal
to point zero zero three now sometimes
students get confused and what I
recommend is take like a percentage that
you're familiar with like 50 percent 50
percent we know as 1/2 and you can see
so how do I get from 50 percent to 1/2 I
move that decimal two places to the left
and I'm getting 0.5 and it makes sense
so sometimes students don't know they
forget it would go right do I go left
take a simple example and you'll be able
to follow that same pattern so for
number 43 it says write the fraction
as a percentage so again we've got a 5/8
we want to go to a percentage so we
would say 5 is being divided by 8 so 8
goes into 5 how many times equals into
five zero eight goes into 50 let's see
six that's forty eight eight goes into
20 how many times let's see about two so
that's 16 and 8 goes into 40 how many
times five so that's a remainder so now
we just have to move that decimal two
places to the right and we've got 62
point five percent okay how about number
forty four now it says 40 point five is
what percent of a hundred and fifty so
there's a formula you might want to
memorize here or write down and it's P
over 100 equals is over off so what this
means is the part out of the whole a
hundred percents like the whole thing is
equal to what is out of the total so
you're thinking part out of the whole
equals part out of the whole those
ratios are the same so here we have
forty point five is so that means 40
point five goes right here okay all
meaning out of 150 what percent we don't
know so we're leave that as a variable P
over 100 so now all you have to do is
cross multiply and solve so we have a
hundred and fifty P equals 40 point five
times 100 what do you multiply by 100
use move that decimal two places to the
right and then if I divide both sides by
150 let's see what that comes out to
four zero five zero divided by 150 27 so
it's 27 percent okay so for number 45 it
says find the percent of change okay so
what exactly is the percent of change
well when you do percent of change what
you do is you look at the amount that
it's changing by so we'll just say the
change divided by the original amount so
what you're trying to figure out is how
is it changing compared to what it was
to begin with so you can see to go from
twelve to twenty dollars like see
somebody raises the price on something
it's going up by eight dollars compared
to what compared to what it was
originally which is twelve dollars now
if we go to the calculator
eight divided by 12 is 0.667 if I round
and then you convert this to a
percentage we're gonna move it decimal
two places to the right so this is
actually a sixty six point seven percent
increase I'm just drawing an up arrow
there to show sixty seven point sixty
six point seven percent increase so just
remember it's that how it's changing
compared to what it was originally now
for forty six it says find a new price
$16.95 Cal what percentage do you pay
well it would be a hundred minus twenty
percent you're actually paying eighty
percent of when you think of all we
think of times so we're taking eighty
percent which is point eight zero as a
decimal times sixteen dollars and let's
see what that comes out to so point
eight times sixteen it's twelve dollars
and eighty cents that's the new price
the other way to do it is you could say
sixteen dollars times 0.2 zero what your
savings are and then subtract it from
sixteen dollars but I find this to be a
little bit easier figure out what you're
actually paying which is one hundred
percent minus 20 percent and multiply by
that quantity you can do it in one step
now for 47 it says find the simple
interest if you have four hundred
dollars invested at two percent for
three years now when we talk about
simple interest here's another formula
you might want to write down its I
equals P times R times T P stands for
the principal that's what you're putting
into your investment four hundred
dollars R is the interest rate but you
want to convert that to a decimal by
moving that decimal point two places to
the left and then T is a time okay in
years three years so if we multiply all
that together that's going to give it
you how much interest that you're
earning total so we have 400 times 0.02
times three so it would be $24 an
interest okay so that's simple interest
I equals prt for 48 though we're doing
compound interest and so the formula
we're going to use here is this formula
a equals P one plus R to the T now this
is when you're only
once per year just annually and so in
this case that's what we have $700
that's your principle that's what you're
starting with and it's 3% so that's
point O three as a decimal and the time
is we'll just leave it s T so with this
which you should leave this as a general
formula here so depending on how many
years you have it invested at you can
calculate the ending amount by putting
in the number of years so one point zero
three it's larger than one you can see
it's growing but that would be your
formula if you're just compounding once
per year so simple interest compound
interest so for number 49 it says is the
relation a functions so what does that
mean relation and function well relation
is like a pairing of an input with an
output okay I domain with a range or an
x value with a Y value so you can see
with these coordinate pairs here we have
inputs paired with outputs but not every
relation is a function okay what you
want is you want for every input you
only want one output so like if you push
a button on your computer and you're
trying to open a program you don't want
it to open one program one time and then
open a different program another time
that's unpredictable right that's not a
function so what we're looking for here
is our inputs five our inputs to our
inputs for our inputs to notice how 2 is
repeated one time two is mapping to
negative three the other time two is
mapping to five we have one input going
to two different outputs that means this
is not a function so I'm going to write
no for that one okay number 50 if f of X
equals 2x minus 3 find F of negative 3
so here what they're testing Isana
is the function notation and what the
wave functions work is whatever is in
the parentheses here you put in for X on
the right now there might be more than
one X on the right you would put in it
for all those X values and in this case
you can see F of negative 3 that means X
is negative 3 so what I'm going to do is
I'm going to replace X with negative 3
and then simplify so 2 times negative 3
is negative 6 minus 3 which is negative
9 so we could say that F of negative 3
equals negative 9 and you got it okay
let's look at number 51 it says write an
equation that describes the sequence 7 9
11 13 15 dot dot dot and then find the
20th term now this is a little bit more
challenging problem and sometimes you
cover this concept when you get to
algebra 2 but let's look at the pattern
here see how it keeps going up by two
each time so we're gonna write this as
two and meaning it's going up by two
each time but let's test this out so if
I put one in here you see how this two
times one is two but the first term is
actually seven that means I have to add
five more like let's test it out again
let's say I put three in it for the
third term two times three is six but I
have to add five more to get 11 so what
I'm doing is I'm realizing I'm going up
by 2 so this is 2 times something 2
times the term that you're on and then
we have to adjust a little bit now
there's more advanced formula like I
said in algebra 2 but for now let's just
write this as our equation we'll call it
a sub N equals 2n plus 5 and the 20th
term we just have to put in 20 now so 2
times 20 is 40 plus 5 is 45 and that's
the value of the 20th term without
having to keep finding the next term
next term next term a little bit more
advanced question there number 52 it
says find the slope the slope is the
rise over the run now when you think of
rise you think of up and down and run
you think of left and right so rise is
also written as a change in Y run is
like change in X but you can see to get
from this point to this point I have to
go down 3 so down is negative and I have
to go right 1 2 3 4 5 6 so right is
positive negative 3 divided by 6 is
negative 1/2
that's our slope you could also go rise
3 that be a positive 3 and then left 6
that'd be a negative 6 but again a
positive everybody negative would give
you the negative 1/2 okay so for number
53 it says find the slope of the line
that goes through these two points if
you want a formula for slope you might
want to write this one down it's y2
minus y1 over x2 minus x1 now when you
think about this point here this is our
first point so we're gonna call that x1
and y1 this is our point number two
we're going to call this x2 and y2 that
you just means point to the X&Y
coordinates so we're gonna do y2 minus
y1
and x-two minus x-one now mistakes that
students sometimes make is that they'll
put the X's in the numerator and the Y's
in the denominator cuz they're thinking
about alphabetical order but it's a
change in Y over the change in X now
when you subtract it's like adding the
opposite 3 minus 2 is 1 and a negative 3
divided by 1 is negative 3 and that's
our slope now for 54 it says what is the
slope and the y-intercept of the this
line right here well what they're
testing us on here is that we really
know our y equals MX plus B form of the
equation of a line this is called the
slope intercept form
M is the slope the number that comes in
front of the X so in this case you can
see that the slope is going to be 5 I'll
just circle that and then B that's our
y-intercept that's the constant and that
in this case the y-intercept is negative
1 so that's our slope and y-intercept so
for 55 it says graph the line now notice
that this is in the y equals MX plus B
form of the equation of a line a slope
intercept form we start with the y
intercept meaning where it crosses the y
axis and that's going to cross that
positive 4 so up 4
put a point and then the slope is
negative 1/2 which means that you're
going to be rising negative 1 so it's
down 1 and then running 2 like that so
again I can repeat that down 1 over 2
down 1 over 2 etc etc so that's the
graph of the line there now for 56 it
says write an equation of line here
we're working backwards we have to come
up with the equation again think about
the y equals MX plus B form the B is the
y-intercept it's crossing at negative 3
on the y axis and then the slope is the
rise over run now see how it's going up
3 and then it's going right 3 so rise 3
run 3 that's going to be 3 over 3 which
equals 1 so this is 1 X minus 3 or you
could just say y equals X minus 3 okay
so 457 it says write an equation of the
line in slope intercept form that goes
through these two points so how would
you do that one well first thing we
needed to do is find the slope so we're
going to go back to our slope formula
right here so y2 minus y1 5 minus
negative 1 over x2 minus x1 4 minus 2
when you subtract remember it's like
adding the opposite
and 6 divided by 2 is 3 so that's our
slope so we're going to start with our y
equals MX plus B for me the equation of
a line and we're going to replace M
which is our slope with 3 but now we
have to find out what the B value is the
y-intercept how do we do that well you
can pick one of these two points it
doesn't matter but you don't want to mix
and match I'll use this point here so 5
is the Y value 4 is the x value and we
just have to solve for B now so 3 times
4 is 12 I subtract 12 from both sides
you can see that B is equal to negative
7 so all we have to do now is put
negative 7 back in for B and we've got
it so y equals 3x minus 7 that's the
equation of our line in slope intercept
form ok number 58 it says write using
exponents so we have 2 times 2 times 2
times 2 times ccccc so here what they're
doing is they're testing us on writing
in exponent form so we've got 2 to the
fourth C to the fifth so this exponent
represents four twos multiplied together
times five C's multiplied together and
we can leave it in that form so 459 it
says is the number prime or composite so
what's a prime number well a prime
number is any number that's only
divisible by 1 and itself where as a
composite number can be divided by other
numbers besides one in itself so we look
at 2727 can be divided by 3 or 9 or so
this one's actually a composite number
whereas when we look at 31 31 can only
be divided by 1 and 31 so this is
actually a prime number so good terms to
review prime and composite so for number
60 it says write the prime factorization
of the number 72 so how would you do
this one well what you can do is you can
break it up using a prime factorization
tree so you can see 8 is like 4 times 2
4 is 2 times 2 9 is 3 times 3 and if you
look at all these ends of the branches
there we've got three twos multiplied
together so that's 2 cubed we have two
threes multiplied together that's three
squared so this is our prime
factorization of 72 it's 2 cubed times 3
squared 4 61 and 62 were simplifying and
again we're
working with the properties of exponents
rules of exponents so how would you
multiply 6x cubed times 5x squared what
would that be well 6 times 5 we know is
30 but when you multiply and you have
the same base see how these are both
base acts you actually add the exponents
3 plus 2 is X to the fifth a meaning we
have five X's multiplied together
whereas when we divide for a number 62
18 divided by three we know that 6 y to
the fifth divided by y squared what is
that that's going to be Y cubed when you
divide you subtract so you can kind of
think of like two of these Y's canceling
with two of these Y's leaving three left
over but the shortcut is when you divide
you take the numerators power minus the
denominators power so for 63 it says
write using positive exponents so see
how this is for Y to the negative three
how would you write that just using a
positive exponent well when you see that
negative exponent it doesn't make the
quantity negative what it tells you to
do is it tells you to move this quantity
to the other side of the fraction bar
tells us to take the reciprocal so what
happens is the four stays in the
numerator because that's not being
affected by the negative three but the Y
to the negative third that's going to
become four over Y cubed okay so for 64
now it says write in standard form now
we're working with scientific notation
2.1 times 10 to the fifth
standard form just means like the
regular form of a number but when you
multiply by 10 to the fifth what you do
is you move this decimal one two three
four five places to the right it's
getting larger so that's going to be to
move that one place that's one and then
we have four placeholders which are the
zeros so it's two hundred and ten
thousand now if this had been two 0.1
times 10 to the negative fifth we would
actually move the decimal point one two
three four five to the left so for
number 65 it says write in scientific
notation so here we're going backwards
here so what you want when you write a
number in scientific notation is you
just want one digit between one and nine
to the left or in front of the decimal
point and then the other significant
digits to the right of the decimal point
and then times ten to a power so here
what I have to do is I have to move this
decimal point right there so that
there's just one digit in front of the
decimal point so this is one point three
times
10 to the 1 2 3 4 this is a negative 4
because the negative when you have a
negative exponent there you move that
decimal 4 to the left and that's going
to be giving us the standard form of the
number now one thing you can remember is
that if it's a really small number see
point zero zero zero this is a really
small number this is going to be a
negative exponent if it's a really large
number it's gonna be a positive exponent
that's just one way to kind of remember
but for this one the decimal point is
right here we really want it to be right
there we want to move it one two three
four five six so there's just one digit
to the left or in front of that decimal
point so this is four point eight one
times 10 to the what do we say one two
three four five six 10 to the sixth
power okay for number 66 we're back to
the rules of exponents simplify x
squared to the fourth power so how would
you do that on what's x squared to the
fourth well when you have a power to a
power what you do is you multiply the
exponents sometimes students get
confused when you multiply you add
exponents but when you have a power to a
power you times the exponents so how
would you do this one three why cubes
the quantity squared well when you
square this what you want to do is
realize that the number also has an
exponent it's just the first power and
you distribute that power on the outside
to these exponents on the inside so this
becomes 3 squared which is 9 and this
becomes 3 times 2 which is y to the 6 so
don't forget to distribute the power to
the number as well as the variable for
number 67 it says is the graph linear or
nonlinear so when we talk about linear
we're talking about straight lines
nonlinear is just like saying it's not a
straight line it's not linear so what do
you think for this one well you can see
it's like more of a curve it's not a
straight line so we would say this one
is nonlinear for 68 it says find the
square root so you recognize this
radical here the square root symbol this
tells us what number times itself is 36
so in this case you can see 6 times 6 is
36 and then times that negative will
make this negative 6 so you work from
the inside out for 69 it says estimate
the square root so square root of 83
what do you think that would be
approximately well we know that the
square root of a hundred
is 10 because 10 times 10 is 100 we know
the square root of 81 is 9 because 9
times 9 is 81
but 83 is closer to 81 than it is to a
hundred so I would say square root of 83
is approximately 9 okay so we're just
rounding to the nearest integer for
number 70 it says find X so you can see
they give us a triangle here what do you
think how would you solve for the
measure of angle X well the thing to
remember is that triangles all the
angles add up to 180
whereas with quadrilaterals four-sided
figures angles add up to 360 so in this
case let's see we've got 88 plus 32 so
that would be how much there'd be a
hundred and 20 so that means that X has
to be 60 degrees okay let's go to number
71 it says classify the triangle by its
sides and its angles so you can see that
there's two sides that are the same see
these marks right here that means that
they're congruent they're the same
length if two sides are the same we call
it isosceles if all three sides are the
same we call it equilateral if they're
all different lengths sides we call it
scalene but for this one it's definitely
isosceles because exactly two sides are
congruent or equal and when you look at
the angles you can see that two of the
angles are you know 15 degrees and one
angle is 150 degrees now if one angle is
greater than 90 then we call it an
obtuse triangle if one of the angles was
90 degrees we call it a right triangle
if all the angles are less than 90
degrees we call it an acute triangle and
if all the angles were 60 degrees we'd
call it an equiangular triangle meaning
all the angles are equal so for this one
I would say isosceles obtuse or obtuse
isosceles either one before we do these
last five problems I hope you've been
enjoying this pre-algebra review if you
want to take your learning deeper with
me check out my algebra 1 video course
for sale I go through a typical algebra
1 curriculum with teaching we go through
the different concepts the formulas and
we go through numerous example problems
also with additional example problems
that you can practice on your own to
really master algebra 1 so check out the
course but let's go through these last
few examples and we'll wrap up this
video number 72 it says find the missing
side so you can see they're giving us a
right triangle here
and we see a right triangle we think
Pythagorean theorem so the famous
Pythagorean theorem looks like this it's
a squared plus b squared is equal to C
squared now a and B are the two sides
that make up the right angle whereas the
C is the longest side it's a side across
from the right angle so if we substitute
in what we have here we have 6 squared
plus x squared equals 10 squared 6
squared is 36 10 squared is 10 times 10
100 if we subtract 36 from both sides of
the equation we get x squared equals 64
and if you take the square root of both
sides you're getting x equals 8 and
that's the missing side okay so for
number 73 now it says find the area of
the trapezoid and remember a trapezoid
is when you have a quadrilateral with
exactly one pair of opposite sides
parallel but these sides are not
parallel remember the formula for area
of a trapezoid it's 1/2 times the height
times the sum of the two bases now the
two bases are the two parallel signs in
this case is going to be 8 and 10 and
then the height is the perpendicular
distance between those two parallel
sides in this case it's 4 so if we
simplify you can see we're getting 18
times 4 times 1/2 1/2 times 4 is 2 2
times 18 is 36 so this is going to be 36
centimeters squared so areas units
squared so you might want to write down
that area of a trapezoid formula 474
we're working with a circle and we want
to find the circumference which is the
distance around the circle and then the
area that's the course the inside of the
circle so a couple more formulas you
want to remember circumference is 2 pi R
so 2 times 3.14 which is pi times the
radius and the area is equal to PI R
squared so the radius squared so for
here the circumference 2 times the
radius would be 2 times 4 which is 8
times pi so that's going to be 8 pi
meters
but the area is pi times 4 squared 4
squared is 4 times 4 which is 16 so we
get 16 pi meters squared 475 now it says
find the mean median and mode we're kind
of talking about statistics a little bit
here me means the average median means
the middle and mode means the one that
occurs the most but when you do this you
want to write the numbers in order from
Lois
to highest so I just rearranged it from
low to high so when we think about the
mean the mean is like the average so we
have to add all these up and divide by
how many we have so we have 5 plus 6
which is 11 plus 7 which is 18 plus 7 is
25 plus 10 is 35 divided by 5 numbers so
you can see that the mean is 7 okay now
for the median that's the middle number
so we have 5 + 10 6 + 7 7 is the one in
the middle so that's going to be our
median if there's two numbers that are
in the middle then what you would do is
you would add them together and divide
by 2 so it's like an average of the two
middle numbers and the mode is the one
that occurs the most so you can see
there's two 7s so the mode is 7 so it
looks like all of our answers came out
to 7 now if there was two 7s and two
sixes then the mode would be 6 and 7 say
for example if all the numbers were
listed just once then there would be no
mode ok and for number 76 it says what
is the probability of drawing a red
marble well when we talk about
probability we're talking about the
number of successful outcomes or I'll
just write the number of successes
divided by the total possible outcome so
if we reach into this hat blindfolded
right we say what's the problem we pick
a red marble well there's 3 red marbles
so 3 chances of picking a red marble a
success / 5 marbles total so our
probability is equal to 3/5 so you got
this if you want to see my algebra one
giant review check out the video right
there and I'll see you over in that
video